Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute zeige ich euch ein sehr stark angefragtes Rezept:
nämlich Nudeln mit einer leckeren Käse Sahnesauce!
Diese Nudeln sind besonders bei Kindern sehr beliebt,
aber auch Erwachsene erfreuen sich ab und zu an dem Genuss
von einer leckeren Käse Sahnesauce!
Wir benötigen Nudeln, ich hab hier Spiralnudeln genommen.
Außerdem Gouda und nehmt da bitte den frischen und reibt ihn am besten selber,
genauso wie beim Parmesan. Außerdem Milch, Sahne, Butter, Mehl,
etwas Gemüsebrühe und ein bisschen Muskatnuss.
Bevor wir mit der Soße anfangen, geben wir zuallererst in kochendes Salzwasser unsere Nudeln.
In einem anderen Topf oder in einer anderen Pfanne geben wir dann die Butter hinein
und lassen sie bei mittlerer Stufe schmelzen.
Danach kommt in einem Schwung das Mehl hinzu und wird gut untergerührt.
So erhalten wir eine Mehlschwitze und sobald ihr merkt, dass das Mehl
so ein wenig anfängt zu blubbern oder Blasen zu bilden, dann ist es genau richtig.
Nun geben wir ganz langsam, immer Schluck für Schluck die Milch mit hinzu.
Macht das am besten wie ich in so einem ganz dünnen Strahl, denn dann
habt ihr wirklich die Garantie, dass sich keine Klumpen bilden.
Sobald ihr dann die Milch komplett eingearbeitet habt, gebt ihr die Sahne mit hinzu.
An der Stelle würzen wir das Ganze auch schon mit der Gemüsebrühe und der Muskatnuss.
Salz wird in der Regel nicht benötigt, denn der Käse ist ja schon salzig genug.
Nun wird das Ganze einmal aufgekocht und anschließend geben wir den Käse mit dazu.
Meine 2 Lieblingskäsesorten für diese Soße sind Goudakäse und Parmesan.
Ihr könnt natürlich den Käse nehmen, der euch am liebsten gefällt.
An der Stelle könnt ihr den Herd auch schon ausschalten
und sobald die gewünschte Sämigkeit erreicht ist, ist eure Käsesoße auch schon fertig.
Für mich ist es perfekt, wenn sie noch  ein wenig flüssig ist. Und wenn die Nudeln auch gar sind,
können wir sie einmal abgießen und mit zur Käse Sahnesoße geben.
Dann wird das Ganze einmal gut untergerrührt und ihr könnt euch die warme Käse Sahnesoße
mit euren Nudeln schmecken lassen!
Falls ihr das Ganze aber jetzt nochmal mit Käse überbacken möchtet, dann tut das gerne!
Einfach die Nudeln in eine Auflaufform legen, Käse darüber geben und so lange bei 180 Grad backen,
bis der Käse geschmolzen ist.
Ich servier das Ganze jetzt noch mit Paprikaflocken und wenn ihr die Nudeln nachmachen möchtet,
dann schaut gerne mal unten in die Infobox, da stehen alle Zutaten mit den genauen Mengenangaben.
Und ich freue mich, wenn ihr in einer Woche zu meinem nächsten Nudelrezept auch wieder einschaltet.
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf kikiskitchen!